[Music]
'icarly is one of the funniest shows for
kids and teenagers and honestly we're
still sad it's over we've recently
rewatched the show and spotted many
mistakes you wouldn't notice unless
you're a true fan wait until you see who
is one of jennette mccurdy stunt doubles
if you love iCarly
give this video a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe let's check out 10
mistakes and icarly
only true fans noticed character
resemblance let's start off with a
little bit of fun only true fans of the
show could catch if you watch ICarly
and victorious you know that both shows
feature some of the same cast they're
either main or side characters but
unless you watch both shows or look it
up you probably never notice it in an
icarly episode called iParty with
victorious the characters of the show's
officially meet for the first time we
see Sam comparing the appearance of Tori
to Shelby Marx an MMA fighter from an
episode in season two well no wonder
they look the same both characters are
played by Victoria Justice but there is
a brief mistake the characters make in
this episode even though they recognize
Tori and Shelby look the same they fail
to recognize some of the other
characters even though it's very clear
that Andre and Harper are both played by
Leon Thomas the third and no one pointed
out the obvious similarities between the
two characters and Trina from victorious
looks like a girl from the ice Aiko
episode because they're both played by
daniella monet that girl even attended
an icarly party before we bet you can
find even more characters in the episode
and it's strange that none of them
recognized anyone else but Victoria
justice it's even funnier when Freddie
says a Tori is actually way hotter than
Shelby Marx
joke's on you Freddie they're the same
person hey guys we are so excited to
announce we are producing our own
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIY fashion tips make a
pact and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it and be sure
to let us know what you think in the
comment section we love to hear from you
Douglas the electrician now let's move
on to some of the serious stuff and one
of the early scenes of season 3 episode
2 Douglas the electrician makes an
appearance he's the guy that installed a
security system in Sam's locker but
that's not what we'll pay attention to
in this episode take a look at the scene
where Sam thanks him you can clearly see
some strings around his neck
can't you he goes on to say that Sam
should tell her mom that Douglas misses
her as they were dating in the past sam
says she will and then Douglas says he
misses her a lot putting a lot of
emphasis on the a lot part you can see
the strings are still around his neck
right pay attention to the next part
as soon as Sam gets angry and says she
gets the innuendo the camera switches to
Douglas and the strings suddenly
disappear this often happens as the
actors do scene takes and nobody really
pays attention to the accessories that
you can clearly see the strings are
missing from his neck they don't appear
for the rest of the shot it could be
that he put them away somewhere or that
simply the actor just made a mistake and
forgot about this small detail perhaps
Douglas the electrician is also a
magician and can make things disappear
in just a second how are they
broadcasting it here's a mistake that's
also in theory we can't check off if you
know the answer to this one let us know
in the comments we follow the iCarly
characters on a lot of adventures and a
lot of the times you see them in places
where it seems like there's absolutely
no internet electricity or outlets if
you're a fan of the show you know they
broadcasted in the studio where there
are a lot of cables involved in tons of
technology that's able to make the show
happen this includes a strong internet
connection that wouldn't be possible
with just a wireless connection now go
back and watch some of the episodes
where the characters clearly visit some
places that wouldn't exactly be ideal
places to live broadcasted show
sometimes even a supply closet or a
closed off place in school might not
have the signal you need to live
broadcast the show so how did they do it
of course it's a show so we can always
just brush this off as part of the story
but doesn't it seem strange how iCarly
is always broadcasted live and seems to
be able to do it from practically
anywhere
we still struggle getting enough signal
or having a strong internet connection
to upload your YouTube videos we know
we're not the only ones that could use
the iCarly's broadcasting magic
honeysuckle next is Freddie's mother
Marissa Benson he probably never liked
her when you watch the iCarly episodes
but did you ever catch this mistake she
made in one of the episodes
she's an overprotective helicopter
parent that always wants to make sure
Freddie is okay she's not really one of
the most loved characters but that
doesn't mean she's not necessary to the
story but that's not the mistake we'll
talk about today in the fourth episode
of season two there's some discussion on
what Marissa's name actually means she
says it means honeysuckle and French but
it's actually wrong honeysuckle is a
completely different word in French and
the name Marissa actually means of the
sea and Mary in Latin there's absolutely
no connection between the name Marissa
and honeysuckle why would she even bring
that up or is it just Marissa's way to
still believe she's really not that
overprotective and is in fact sweet
another quick mistake actually comes
from the same episode in the hospital
scene we see Sam discovering lewbert's
wart
on Carly Shue Freddie takes it off and
gives it to the paramedics but in the
next hospital scene we see Carly with
both shoes on the same shoes she was
wearing before guess the paramedics
didn't want to keep the shoes after all
no matter how gross they were magical
dentists you can argue that iCarly had
so many seasons mistakes were not
allowed to happen but mistakes and
iCarly could be spotted from as early as
season one sometimes it's even the
actors fault but sometimes it's just the
way the scenes are shot as actors have
to redo the same takes over and over
again
only the best ones get picked and
sometimes that means the background in
those scenes might be inconsistent
you've probably seen a bunch of the ECP
watch ICarly or many other shows if not
make sure you watch our other videos
where we explore the mistakes on Jessie
Despicable Me and many more shows and
movies these kind of mistakes also
happened in season 1 episode 14 called I
heart arts let's go to the scene with
the dentist pay attention to Spencer's
shirt every time the camera pans back to
Spencer you can see the web stain on his
shirt going small
all while he's still drooling either the
saliva is drying superfast or there were
so many takes done they no longer paid
attention to the little details also
this team might seem pretty gross if
you're not a fan of drooling we bet you
can find even more seems like that so
next time you watch ICarly pay attention
to objects and stains and see if they
disappear at any point during the same
scene time goes slow if you're still
watching our video leave a comment
saying team icarly to let us know how
many times of these mistakes have you
caught so far we bet you've seen this
one because it's something that happens
in action movies and it's often
completely unexplainable we've all seen
countdowns with a timer that goes much
slower than it would in real life it's
TV magic after all icarly also had a
scene where it seemed like seven seconds
lasted for longer than seven seconds
it's episode 20 of season 2 called I
fight Shelby Marx at the beginning of
the episode you can see everyone
watching Shelby fight on TV the timer
shows there's only 7 seconds of fighting
left but the fight itself was much
longer than that
it's like time completely stopped and
was only added for the dramatic suspense
like it is in most action movies if you
focus on details when watching the show
read back this caught your eye it seems
like one second in the TV world becomes
one minute sometimes even more maybe
it's the magic of Shelby Marx
speaking of Shelby Marx you probably
know by now that she's played by
Victoria Justice when the iCarly
characters to meet the characters of
Victorious you can see Sam comparing
Tori to Shelby they're the same people
we bet that blew everyone's mind when
they watch the episode for the first
time the change of the Hammers iCarly is
a show with a lot of background objects
that never really leave the set but we
bet that you can find a few that change
either intentionally or unintentionally
in season 1 episode 5 called I want to
stay with Spencer Spencer gets inspired
to build a fan of hammers and he's
really excited about it it's just as
crazy as it sounds a fan with spinning
hammers attached to it it doesn't really
sound safe and that
proven when Spencer turns it on because
one of the hammer ends up in the wall
but pay attention to the way the hammers
are facing when they're attached to the
fan they're all facing the same
direction with the peen facing the left
since the fan is spinning clockwise
there will be no way the hammer would
end up in a wall the way it did besides
that we can see the peen of the hammer
in the wall but surely the hammer would
make some kind of damage to the wall
considering the speed of the fan if you
look at the wall it's completely
undamaged and the hammer just looks like
it's part of the decoration another
funny gag is that that particular hammer
actually stays in the wall for the rest
of the show but we bet you can spot a
scene where it suddenly disappears
stunt-double revealed although it was
noted that jennette mccurdy loves to do
her own stunts there were several
occasions where she had to get a stunt
double sometimes there will masked and
sometimes there totally obvious I saved
your life has to be one of the funniest
episodes of the show as we saw Spencer
and Sam try to hit each other with the
blowgun we love the suspense when the
mailman opens up the package and Spencer
asks of Sam's inside he discovers a
lollipop and the mailman mentions is
actually called a sucker then we see Sam
popping up from the ceiling in slow
motion if you pause the scene when Sam
lands on the floor you can easily see
it's actually a stunt double as it
completely reveals her face her name is
Jessie cotton linear but you'd never
know unless you check the credits for
the episode we have to say the
slow-motion shot of Sam jumping down is
one of our favorites in that same
episode
Spencer makes a very inappropriate joke
we see Sam opening her locker and
finding Spencer inside who's ready to
shoot her with the blowgun Sam just
slams the door in his face and locks the
Locker we hear Spencer say he needs to
stop saying witty things before he blows
all right Spencer that might be a little
too much for a kids show Sam sandwich
here's another mistake where the show
didn't pay much attention to the objects
around the actors as they did multiple
takes to find the right one this also
happened in one of the earlier episodes
in season 1 episode 18 we can see Sam
eating a sandwich when they have the
first meeting with the techfoot company
watch closely as the camera focuses on
Sam and the sandwich on the
you can see her eating a sandwich but
the amount she has eaten changes with
each shot and it's not decreasing like
any other sandwich you would eat this
magical sandwich actually has a bite
taken in one shot but then looks whole
in another the shots go back and forth
and it seems like the sandwich always
has a bite taken out of it or it doesn't
the sandwich also rotates sometimes its
face towards Sam and sometimes it isn't
and when Sam chokes on the sandwich
after finding out how much they get paid
for the shoe promotion you can clearly
see it's still whole pretty confusing
right even though we do see her moving
her mouth as if she'd be eating the
sandwich well it's definitely not the
first time it has happened and we're
sure you can find more mistakes like
this if there's one thing we learned in
that episode it's that you shouldn't buy
techfoot shoes and stuntmen we've
already talked about stunt doubles in
this video but it's always fun when you
realize that the actor that's supposed
to play the character changed into
someone else they often look so similar
it's super easy to miss it and unless
you're huge icarly fan you've probably
missed this piece of trivia we've
mentioned jennette mccurdy as love doing
her own stunts but sometimes she had to
get a stunt double in episode 6 of
season 3 we see Sam lifting Freddie
while it's not a mistake by itself it
would be pretty hard for Sam to lift
Freddie up without any issues
considering she struggled with heavy
objects in some of the previous episodes
we never actually see Sam's face but
there's a good reason behind it jennette
mccurdy actually revealed that she had a
stunt double for that scene but what's
really surprising is that her stunt
double was actually a man his name is
Shawn Lucerne and were honestly
surprised Nickelodeon was able to pull
this off
rewind the scene where Sam picks up
Freddie again and see if you can spot
the sim actually becomes a male's stunt
double Jeanette said her confidence
plumbin when she learned that her stunt
supple was going to be a man but we bet
it's not even noticeable unless you're a
true icarly fans
that's it for 10 mistakes and icarly
only true fans notice for more iCarly
videos check out 10 behind-the-scenes
secrets in iCarly
Nickelodeon tried to hide see you next
time
[Music]